- [Presenter] Did you know that there are
more than 4 million people
who live in American territories
that aren't part of the 50 US states?
In fact, the US claims 16 territories
outside of the continental United States,
although a few of those are in
dispute with other countries
and only five of them are
permanently inhabited.
So where are these territories?
Let's look at a map.
Most of the territories
are here in the Pacific.
The inhabited territories here are Guam,
the Northern Mariana
Islands and American Samoa.
Then there are two here in the Caribbean,
the US Virgin Islands and Puerto Rico.
You may also be surprised to learn
that the capital of the
United States, Washington,
is in a special geographic
and political zone
called the District of Columbia,
which is also not a state.
The most populous territory
by far is Puerto Rico
with more than 3 million residents.
Its population is greater
than 19 of the US states,
putting it just behind Utah
but ahead of Iowa in numbers.
The District of Columbia has
more than 700,000 residents,
putting it ahead of just
two states in population.
The other four territories
are much smaller
with between 50,000 and 200,000 residents.
The citizenship status and voting rights
of the people living in these territories
might be different from
residents of the states.
Let's delve a little bit
more into these differences.
Most people living in
the American territories
are granted US citizenship at birth,
although that has not
always been the case.
Although white people born
in the District of Columbia
have had citizenship at birth
from the creation of the district in 1790,
the large black population of the city
didn't gain citizenship protections
until the passage of the
14th Amendment in 1868.
Over the course of the 20th century,
the residents of four
of the other territories
have gotten citizenship
status by various means,
starting with Puerto Rico by
an act of Congress in 1917.
The US Virgin Islands gained citizenship
by congressional order in 1927.
The 1952 Immigration and
Nationality Act expanded
the definition of who received
US citizenship at birth
to include Guam.
And residents of the
Northern Mariana Islands
became citizens when their territory
became a Commonwealth in 1976.
The residents of American Samoa
are currently US nationals,
not US citizens.
This means that they
have the right to travel
and live in the United States.
And they're afforded
protection by the United States
when traveling abroad,
but they don't qualify for other
benefits of US citizenship,
like the right to vote.
But that might change soon.
Right now, a case which
is seeking US citizenship
for American Samoans,
Fitisemanu versus the United States,
is making its way through
the federal court system.
So we may hear a ruling
on this case this year.
The citizens of the territories
and Washington DC have many
of the same citizenship
rights and responsibilities
as citizens of the states.
Remember, because American
Samoans are US nationals
rather than citizens,
their situation is a little bit different.
So what I'm about to say
does not apply to them.
The citizens of the
territories have the right
to move freely within the United
States without a passport.
They also have the right to
vote in presidential primaries
but not in presidential elections.
We'll talk more about
voting rights in a sec,
because DC is also a bit
different in this regard.
Citizens in the territories
also have most of the same
civil and political rights
as the people in the states,
and their responsibilities
are also much the same.
Although they don't have
to pay federal income tax,
they do have to pay other federal taxes
like Social Security and Medicare.
They also must defend the
country when called upon
and obey federal laws and regulations.
However, even though the citizens
of the territories and Washington DC have
to obey federal laws,
pay federal taxes and defend
the country when called upon,
they do not have any voting
representation in Congress.
Each of the territories has a delegate
in the House of Representatives.
But although those delegates
may participate and debate
and sit on committees,
they may not cast votes.
The citizens of Puerto Rico, Guam,
the US Virgin Islands
and the Northern Mariana Islands can vote
for their territorial governor,
their delegate in the House
and in presidential primaries.
The citizens of Washington DC can vote
for their mayor and City Council,
although Congress has the authority
to block any laws passed by that council,
if they disagree with them.
DC citizens may vote in
presidential elections as well.
The 23rd Amendment to the US
Constitution, ratified in 1961,
gave the district three votes
in the electoral college
for the election of the
president and the vice president.
So what do you think about
citizenship and voting rights
in the territories and in
the District of Columbia?
How are they different from those
of the citizens of the states?
And how are they similar?
Why do you think they're different?
And do you think they should be?